[Music]
well a functioning and clean bathroom
it's what every tenant wants to have but
at 8 news now viewer reached out to us
after he says his bathroom has been
overflowing with fecal matter it's
happening at the Greenville Park
apartments near Sahara and Arville the
tenant tells our Victoria Saha the
solutions from maintenance worker are
just a temporary Band-Aid do be aware
that some of this footage may not be
easy to look at
the thought of a sewage leak in your
home seems pretty unpleasant right well
some residents here at Greenville
Apartments tell me that they've had
sewage leaking into their apartment not
once but several times since January and
there hasn't been a permanent fix this
one right here that was Saturday
it was disgusting yuck is what some of
you at home are thinking now what I have
to do is put on shoes and then also put
bags over those shoes while I'm in the
shower this tenant asked to remain
anonymous but wants the public to see
the sewage that keeps coming into his
bathroom the feces will come from the
sewage drain it will link leak from
below the faucet and then it will start
to rise from the toilet leaving the
tenant and his young son without a
bathroom for days the issue has only
worsened his neighbors also sharing
these images it's been happening every
few days since January and every time
there's a work order completed to drain
the tub but this is what's left for
residents to clean up a foul smell is
hard to breathe so why is this happening
I went to the leasing office to get
answers what is being done to
permanently fix the sewage issue
do you think it's okay for these
residents to live in those conditions I
was told to contact their corporate
office so we talked to a marketing
director for Westland real estate Dino
Lerner Lerner says they brought in
plumbing experts to find the cause the
answer residents are using flushable
light I asked her why residents had to
clean up the aftermath would you in
their shoes be the ones wanting to clean
this up
Westland has never asked a resident to
clean up an issue like this
but they're saying they never had
someone come to them offering to clean
it up I don't know how someone can sleep
at night knowing that people are living
like this
the marketing director also told
Victoria that residents need to stop
flushing wipes in order for the sewage
backup to stop now Victoria has
requested the marketing manager provide
a copy of the report from plumbers
saying flushable wipes are causing the
issue she's still waiting for them for
more in this story use your cell phone
camera to scan this QR code on your
screen it will take you to 8newsnow.com
where the story will be on the front
page